entendeur légaux souple est pressé les
élèves de sortir de l'école on regarde
le marteau l'année ton et al on n'est
pas avec des gens qu'on connaît et
tenter de limiter les attroupements les
habitudes et la configuration de l'école
ont été changés tous pour éviter des
éclosions de coronavirus ici on a
aménagé une salle d'isolement réserve en
cas d'accord pour l'instant calixa
lavallée n'a pas eu de cas d'infection
ici les élèves respectent les consignes
on était triste de ne pas aller à
l'école pendant six mois ils veulent pas
d'éclosion à l'intérieur de l'école mais
difficile pour l'école de contrôler ce
qui se passe hors de ses murs à partir
du moment où la santé publique parle
d'éclosion ou que plusieurs cas c'est
vraiment le sujet ce qui va venir nous
soutenir
une roulotte qui peut venir ici à
l'école pour faire un dépistage massif
une roulotte format géant une unité de
détection mobile qui peut être
fonctionnel en quelques heures
quatre personnes peuvent y être testées
en même temps un outil rendue
essentielle par l'ouverture des écoles
qui a des jeunes qui vont à l'école qui
était pas le printemps pour la région de
montréal
donc on se prépare on se reparlera
sûrement avoir plus de cas de dépistage
aussi affaire à tous les jours
l'objectif identifier rapidement les
lieux d'éclosion pour éviter la
transmission protéger les plus
vulnérables et empêcher une autre
catastrophe dans les chu celle d où
malgré tout on se prépare au pire
le ch est celle des laurendeau sera sur
la ligne de front ici plus de 80
résidents sont morts de la coved
il y a donc assez d espace pour qu'on
libère tout un étage qui servira si les
éclosions se multiplient c'est plus pour
que vive positif dans ce siège celle
d'e.on a déjà aménagé 49 chambres qui
pourrait servir à héberger ici des
patientes d'autres ch et celle des
infectés par le coronavirus et les
hôpitaux comme sacré coeur seront mieux
préparés qu'au printemps
on y construit une annexe de 96 chambres
pour continuer d'opérer des passes
un sans risquer de les contaminer et
dans l'hôpital aussi les choses ont
évolué on nous amène dans la zone chaude
pour mieux comprendre
l'équipement est les protocoles de
protection sont maintenant au point
parce qu'on connaît mieux le virus mais
il a fallu moderniser la ventilation
d'une centaine de chant succès va la
faire rétablir une pression négative à
l'intérieur de la pièce pour faire en
sorte que on aspire l'air vers
l'extérieur et même ajouter des
divisions de fortune pour isoler les
ombres éventuellement contaminés c'est
une éthique je prendrai la fidh
télescopique
en fait on peut au fur et à mesure qu'on
augmente le nombre de patients fermer
les portes pour agrandir la zone chaude
une grande question demeure
aura-t-on assez d'infirmières pour tenir
le coup on essaie de prévoir plus de
vraiment pensé à tous les scénarios
possibles
en espérant qu'ils aient pas d'autres
surprises madeleine alfred qui a vécu la
première vague se dit prête pour new
town très positive fatiguée mais positif
parce qu on en garde un bon moral
on va passer à internet passe on est une
bonne équipe mais tout le monde dans le
réseau de la santé se réjouit de
l'arrivée de centaines de nouveaux
préposés ici david gêne-t-il et radio
canada montréal